Ukraine's President Vladimir zinski says
ke is launching a criminal investigation
after a Russian missile strike on Friday
reportedly killed at least 19 soldiers
local media says that attack happened
near the Frontline in the zapar Asia
region as an award ceremony for a
military Brigade was underway let's
bring in our correspondent in keave Rob
McBride who is joining us on the newsour
what more do we know Rob about this
incident and what are the political
ramifications
yeah this is causing some political
repercussions some backlash uh here in
uh K and also a criticism of the
Ukrainian military leadership all of
this unfolded last Friday uh with a
squad a large unit of men from a
mountain assault Brigade from
transcarpathia this is a region in the
far west of Ukraine now they have been
deployed down on the uh front in the
south in the zapara uh region it does
appear as though a large group of
soldiers from this unit were back from
the front line attending a ceremony at a
village just over 20 kilm away from at
the front line and it appears this was
detected by a Russian drone now footage
that has been released through a Russian
telegram Channel appears to show this
event this ceremony being tracked and
then the same Drone footage appears to
show a very large explosion uh resulting
in these uh deaths and injuries now the
ukrainians say that the Russians fire an
isander short range ballistic uh missile
and there has been widespread
condemnation uh on mainstream media and
also online by lawmakers and Military
bloggers here in Ukraine of just how the
Ukraine Armed Forces appeared to allow
this large Gathering of soldiers in one
place presenting such a Target uh for
the Russians and it's criticism that's
also been echoed by Vladimir zelinsky
the president here who says that this
was an avoidable tragedy right and and
what's been happening elsewhere in
Ukraine ukine what's the latest on on
the counter
offensive uh there have been more
exchanges um especially attacks by waves
of drones and also missiles overnight
from uh uh from Russian forces on the
southern city of adessa which has been
constantly attacked now for a number of
weeks and months um a number of of the
drones were intercepted but that damage
was reported to a number of buildings
including an historic art museum PA
infrastructure a number of other
buildings on the ground with around
eight people being reported injured
there have also been attacks by the
so-called Glide bombs in the southern
hon region of Ukraine and all this does
seem to be uh following an attack by
Ukrainian cruise missiles against a
large Shipyard the ziv shipyard that's
in the Kirch Port which is right over on
the Eastern tip of the occupied Crimean
uh Peninsula which does appear to have
damaged a Russian Naval vessel as we see
this continuing uh tit fatat exchange of
drone uh and missile attacks between
Russian and Ukrainian forces Rob thank
you for the update Rob MC rde life for
usir in keev